et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sébastien Chenu bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous député du Nord
vice-président du rassemblement national
vice-président de l'Assemblée nationale
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
Christelle Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche
bonjour Christelle bonjour Oriane
bonjour Sébastien bonjour on va
évidemment parler de la réforme de
retraite Sébastien Chenu les députés qui
ont donc rejeté cette nuit
l'instauration d'un index senior premier
revers pour le gouvernement vous y êtes
opposé comme la gauche une quarantaine
de députés les républicains que
dites-vous de ce vote
d'abord c'est index nous nous n'avons
pas voté le rassemblement national a
refusé de le voter parce que en fait
c'était une sorte de gadget ça n'avait
pas beaucoup d'intérêt ce n'est pas un
index qui fait une politique en faveur
des seniors en faveur de l'emploi des
seniors et donc ça alourdissait de façon
totalement inutile le les marges de
manoeuvre des entreprises sans produire
de résultats donc
je pense que c'est pas le bon outil tout
simplement parce qu'il y a des index qui
existent sur l'emploi des femmes sur des
travailleurs handicapés etc ça ne
produit pas de résultats en fait c'est
une contrainte souvent supplémentaire
une contrainte administrative mais qui
ne produit pas de résultats donc c'est
pas une réponse à la politique des
seniors on peut ouvrir d'ailleurs et
nous c'est ce que Marine Le Pen a
demandé ouvrir un débat sur
l'employabilité des seniors c'est même
une nécessité vous savez que 42% des
seniors arrivent à l'âge de la retraite
sans être dans le monde de l'emploi
c'est-à-dire ils sont où au chômage ou
sans emploi ou au RSA donc là il y a un
vrai sujet et puis la deuxième chose
hier de ce rejet donc ça c'est sur le
fond c'est pas c'était pas une bonne
proposition c'est que ça dit que
l'obstruction n'est pas une une fin en
soi lorsqu'on vote on peut mettre le
gouvernement donc en minorité on peut
s'opposer à la réforme des retraites à
travers le vote et pas à travers
l'obstruction et donc ça veut dire que
ce que nous défendons nous les députés
du rassemblement national ce n'est pas
été là hier soir ça passait l'index et
bien ce que nous défendons c'est à dire
le vote le débat puis le vote et non pas
l'obstruction comme d'autres ont tenté
de le faire ça a du sens parce que on
arrive à s'opposer à mettre le
gouvernementaires on n'est pas là
uniquement pour j'allais dire pour faire
du blabla on est là pour voter et quand
on vote on peut mettre le gouvernement
en minorité avant d'en venir à
l'obstruction juste en mot sur le fond
de cette de cette amendement sur l'index
Seigneur ça veut dire qu'on en parle
quand l'employabilité des seigneurs si
on parle pas maintenant vous avez raison
c'est une proposition qui a fait
d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen c'était
immédiatement de travailler ensemble sur
une grande loi des seniors qui pourrait
comporter plusieurs volets qui arrive au
printemps par exemple ça pourrait être
cette loi travail évidemment elle
pourrait en faire partie par exemple le
fait de faire en sorte que les seniors
soient des travailleurs protégés ce qui
permettrait de les licencier très
difficilement à la fin de leur parcours
le fait d'avoir un seuil minimum
d'employés du secteur privé qui au-delà
de 45 ans pour être employé dans la
fonction publique ce qui leur
garantirait un emploi jusqu'à la
retraite il y a plusieurs propositions
et là-dessus il faut être assez ouvert
un vrai projet de société que celui que
de l'employabilité des seniors il faut
en parler on a des propositions à faire
on en a fait j'ajoute aussi que l'index
pour rester sur sur le fond était un
outil qui était ce qu'a dit Laurent
Fabius le président du Conseil
constitutionnel qui n'aurait pas passé
la rampe du Conseil constitutionnel donc
en plus sincèrement tout ça a été
totalement bidon et c'est ce qu'on a
dénoncé depuis le passage en Commission
on a vu les députés se lever à après le
vote de cette réforme est-ce que vous le
voyez vous comme un revers pour le
gouvernement ou c'est en vote normal à
l'Assemblée c'est un revers pour le
gouvernement à partir du moment où le
gouvernement présentait cet index et
qu'il en faisait un peu l'un de ces
étendards il nous expliquait que grâce à
cet index on allait solutionner l'emploi
des séances c'est totalement à côté de
la plaque donc oui c'est un c'est une
première gifle pour le gouvernement et
ça montre bien que le travail
parlementaire peut avoir cette utilité
pour vous du vote de l'article 7 ou de
de la globalité du projet de loi
ça présage encore rien mais ça envoie un
signe ça montre que c'est possible et
puis je pense que ça permet de mettre
chacun devant ses responsabilités les
députés LR hier ils ont voté contre
l'index avec nous les députés du
rassemblement national avec les députés
de la gauche donc les députés LR doivent
prendre leur responsabilité sur
l'ensemble de ce texte or on sait qu'il
y a un débat chalet il y a une pression
qui est mise sur les députés à l'air
pour voter la réforme des retraites la
pression de la direction DLR direction
qui ont passé un accord avec le
gouvernement alors même que beaucoup de
députés
par Elisabeth borne reprend ce qui est
voté par le Sénat depuis quatre ans et
ce qui est bien dit rappelez-vous le
fameux accord sur les 1200 euros c'était
le deal des républicains d'ailleurs ils
ont même dit grâce à nous tout le monde
aura une retraite de 1200 euros par mois
en fait on est en train de s'apercevoir
que ce deal est un deal pourri il y a
pas de Français qui vont avoir une tous
les entendu tous les retraités auront
1200 euros net par mois on s'aperçoit ce
sera brut qu'il faut avoir fait toute
une carrière au SMIC que les carrières
rachetées notamment des femmes et bien
sûr que les notamment des femmes seront
pas prises en compte bref en fait il y
aura 60000 personnes je crois qui chaque
année pourront avoir les 1200 euros
enfin sur les chiffres on est absolument
pas d'accord en tout cas ce sera très
faible par rapport au nombre de
personnes concernées et cette cet accord
qui avait revendiqué à l'air en disant
on a obtenu ça et bien tombe
un plus d'un million quasiment 2
millions de Français verront leur
retraite augmentée de 57 euros en
moyenne non mais ça c'est les chiffres
de Bruno Le Maire c'est pas du tout
grâce à l'alignement des 1200 euros
c'est pas ça les 1200 euros nous on leur
demande et d'ailleurs le gouvernement
n'a pas été capable de nous le dire
combien de personnes seront concernées
par les 1200 euros net de toute façon
c'est pas 1900 Rennes c'est 1200 euros
brut dans la bouche du gouvernement donc
on voit bien que ce qu'ils appelaient le
sucré pour faire passer le salé de la
réforme c'est à dire leur port de en
réalité et bien est tombé à l'eau donc
je regle le la boucle les LR ayant raté
ce deal avec le gouvernement vont-ils
accepter une réforme si injuste vous
vous discutez régulièrement avec eux
vous sentez le groupe divisé
si vous voulez moi je vois sur certains
textes de voter contre l'ensemble du
texte
qui sont capables de le faire moi je
vois des textes sur des textes vous avez
trois députés LR dans votre four dans
votre compte et l'autre s'abstient donc
il y a plus aucune ligne directrice chez
LR c'est un canard sans tête mais je
pense qu'il y a du bon sens chez
certains députés LR qui ont compris sur
le terrain que les Français ne veulent
pas de cette réforme je vous rappelle
que 94% des actifs la refuse et donc je
pense que s'ils sont logiques ils
n'imposeront pas ils ne contribueront
pas à imposer une réforme dans les
Français ne veulent pas et ils voter en
faisant fi puisqu'ils se sont fait élire
bien souvent comme il le disent sur leur
nom eux-mêmes et pas sur leur étiquette
qui avait effectivement été plutôt
étiquette catastrophique au moment des
élections présidentielles et bien en
étant des gens libres en faisant preuve
de cette liberté intérieure et de ce
courage que nous leur demandons et bien
ils pourront votre compte oui bien sûr
un nouveau pas hier sur la question des
carrières longues le gouvernement a donc
déposé un amendement pour les 20-21 ans
je cite qui pose le principe que dès
lors qui est atteint l'âge de départ
anticipé la réforme ne prévoit pas pour
les carrières longues de durée de
cotisation supérieure à 43 ans les gens
qui ont commencé à travailler à 17 ans
seront aussi concernés est-ce que vous
saluez cette avancée non mais c'est
cosmétique d'abord c'est totalement flou
on sait pas si c'est un rendement si ça
passera par décret le gouvernement n'a
pas été quand même de le dire hier et
les gens qui ont commencé à 16 ans
puisque il y a des gens qui ont commencé
à 16 ans même en cueillant même encore
une génération dont certains ont
commencé à 14 ou 15 ans pour eux il y a
rien du tout donc on voit bien que c'est
un brique d'aller plus loin pour les 14
ans les saisons les 18 ans doivent
encore cotiser 44 mais là dessus non
mais c'est pas ça parce que quand on est
dans cette logique là qui est celle de
bricolage mais qui est celle de
aujourd'hui de revenir sur ces carrières
on sait très bien que ce gouvernement
reste dans la même logique et que donc
dans deux ans il aurait proposé à une
une loi pour aller à 64 ans puis à 65
ans ils sont dans la même logique c'est
un bricolage simplement
utile pour essayer d'obtenir les voies
des républicains visiblement bien sûr
aujourd'hui qui doivent cotiser 45 45
ans des carrières longues on peut le
faire à l'avenir c'est un bricolage
parce que dans deux ans ce sera remis en
cause et puis il y a pas l'impact
financier n'a même pas été calculé ni
présenté au Parlement ce qui vous
indique que ça pas été très réfléchi et
que c'est un peu un sauve qui peut de
dernière minute où c'est une réforme on
nous a dit cette réforme elle va
rapporter 17 milliards dans les caisses
de l'État et quand vous regardez ce que
l'ensemble des amortisseurs écoute les
1200 euros brut ils avaient annoncé aux
Français que ce serait net aujourd'hui
ils nous disent bruts etc à la fin en
fait ça fait déjà 16 milliards oui mais
on l'a déjà calculé ça fait déjà 16
milliards donc on est en train de
brutaliser la société française pour un
gain de deux ou trois milliards sans
compter jusqu'à annoncé hier elisab ces
gens là cette majorité est totalement
irresponsable
vous avez 11 milliards sur les
amortisseurs et 5 milliards sur les 1200
euros alors aujourd'hui vous demandez à
la nuque de retirer tous ces amendements
pour arriver très rapidement à la
discussion sur l'article 7 eux disent si
on suit la logique du rassemblement
national le texte serait déjà voté et on
n'aurait pas pu laisser à la rue le
temps de s'exprimer ils ont pas tout à
fait tort là-dessus ils ont totalement
temps parce qu'ils sont dans une logique
d'obstruction pour deux raisons la
première il contrairement à nous qui
demandons qu'on vote qu'on débatte puis
qu'on vote et on a vu que ça pouvait
marcher on l'a vu hier la nuit pêche
redoutait ce vote redoutait qu'une
majorité se constitue pour soutenir
cette réforme et nous c'était l'inverse
nous on pensait que par le débat on a
les démontrer avec nos arguments avec le
jeu parlementaire on allait démontrer à
nos collègues des républicains on l'a vu
hier qu'il était possible qui est pas de
majorité qui se construisent pour se
vote et puis la deuxième chose la
technique de l'obstruction
et la violence de la nups en particulier
de la France insoumise que les Français
découvrent les insultes la brutalité des
propos et bien révèle quelque chose
c'est pas uniquement des gens mal élevés
ce sont des gens qui ont intellectualisé
la conflictualité des rapports
politiques c'est à dire que tout doit
être un conflit c'est-à-dire que ils
veulent ils le disent ils s'engagent pas
ils veulent déconstruire les
institutions de la République
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat la police
la justice pour repartir sur autre chose
des assemblées populaires que ça je
faisais prête pour des révolutionnaires
de 1789 donc ça veut dire que sont des
gens qui ont un projet de société qui
repose d'abord sur une certaine forme de
brutalité qui s'éloigne beaucoup des
institutions de la Cinquième République
et sincèrement s'ils étaient au pouvoir
enfin vous voyez ce que ça voudrait dire
quand on voit Aurélien Saintoul qui
insulte un ministre d'assassins à
l'autre avec un ballon de foot et
provocations permanentes des députés de
la France insoumise sincèrement on se
dit que pour préserver le pays faut pas
que ces gens un jour arrivent au pouvoir
alors vous vous a fait le je fais le
choix de déposer assez peu d'amendements
vous intervenez assez peu dans
l'hémicycle on a du mal à comprendre les
positions du rassemblement national
pourquoi le choix de cette stratégie
finalement le flou ça vous arrange non
pas du tout d'abord on intervient autant
que possible par rapport aux règles du
jeu parlementaire il y a une espèce de
d'illusion artificielle sur les
interventions puisque la nupaisses a
déposé 15000 amendements ou 20 000
amendements mais qui sont des
amendements répétitifs et on change une
virgule on change un pourcentage on
change une date et comme ça on
intervient à chaque fois et ça c'est de
l'obstruction nous on a déposé des
amendements de fonds et on a vu que
lorsqu'on parle du fond ce qu'on pense
que les Français ils veulent parler du
fond et bien on va au débat et on va au
vote c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
la nuit pêche on leur a demandé de
retirer leurs amendement bidon ils ont
retiré donc on a pu parler de l'article
2 et on a pu le voter et mettre en
minorité le gouvernement c'est à dire
que ce qu'on propose comme approche du
débat elle est efficace c'est pas
l'obstruction c'est efficace et par
exemple on a du mal à comprendre notre
position sur le premier vous avez été
contre la suppression des régimes
spéciaux dans ces régimes spéciaux il y
a les employés du CESU de la Banque de
France l'éclairs de notaire pourquoi
voter contre la suppression de cette
débats parce que nous on considère qu'il
y a des régimes spéciaux qui peuvent
être maintenus qui doivent être
maintenues parce que oui être chauffeur
d'un bus RATP chauffeur d'un train ce
sont des horaires contraignants ça des
contraintes un régime spécial ça
correspond à des contraintes en revanche
nous avons indiqué que pour la Banque de
France ou le 16e il était possible de
revenir sur ses régimes spéciaux il faut
les prendre un par un il faut les
Serrier regarder ce qui mérite un régime
spécial et il y a des professions qu'il
méritent et il y a pas de raison de les
laisser tomber les pompiers aussi les
agents défenses de l'ordre et puis il y
a des gens qui dans l'évolution des
carrières ou dont le métier aujourd'hui
n'a pas de contrainte si particulière
qu'elle nécessite un régime spécial sur
la suite parce que ça fait 10 jours que
vous avez commencé l'examen de ce texte
vous en êtes à peine à l'article 2 qui a
été voté cette nuit reste deux jours et
demi vous pensez vraiment pouvoir
arriver à un vote et bien nous redisons
la même chose à la gauche retirez vos
amendements bidon si vous retirez 15000
amendements qui sont artificiels qui ne
nourrissent pas le débat on va arriver à
l'article 7 qui est l'article symbolique
je le rappelle c'est celui qui décale
l'âge de départ en retraite à 64 ans on
va pouvoir le voter et mettre en
minorité ce gouvernement et aussi faire
en sorte que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités il faut aller à cet
article 7 pour ça il faut que les
députés de la nupaise de la France
insoumise retire tout ce folklore
d'amendement qui en bouteille qui
embouteille pardon les débats et qui n'a
pas strictement rien leur argument c'est
dire cet article sera voté on n'aura pas
la majorité et du coup la contestation
dans la rue est complètement étouffée
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que ce risque
n'est pas réel
leur argument pour déposer des
amendements et faire de l'obstruction
ils avaient peur que effectivement ils
prennent ils ne veulent pas aller au
vote nous on pense d'abord que dans une
démocratie le vote c'est la meilleure
réponse le vote référendum je vous
rappelle qu'on a aussi proposé que les
Français puissent obtenir un référendum
sauf qu'ils ne l'ont pas voté il y a eu
aucune voie de la nups pour voter la
proposition de référendum donc on a
toujours l'impression que la nuit pèse
pour mettre des gens des têtes au bout
d'une pique des têtes sur des ballons de
foot pour hurler pour brailler pour
faire l'obstruction pour tout casser ils
sont là mais lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre
ses responsabilités voter aller au
référendum débattre du fond je rappelle
qu'on a plein d'amendements dont on veut
débattre
personne mais avec le vote sur l'article
7 et sur l'ensemble du texte vous pensez
vraiment pouvoir mettre en échec le
gouvernement je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est d'ailleurs il le disent
même n'est pas sûr d'avoir une majorité
pour faire passer ce texte qui je le
rappelle est rejeté par les Français
comment peut-on imposer aux Français un
texte qui est à ce point rejeté par le
peuple français alors justement vous
parlez de ce texte qui rejeté par le
peuple français demain la journée de
grève ne s'annonce pas très suivie
est-ce que pour vous c'est le début de
la fin de la comtesse
ont été beaucoup plus fortes on l'a vu
samedi des journées de mobilisation
beaucoup plus fortes on voit que dans le
pays il y a une mobilisation importante
alors ça peut être un peu plus haut un
peu plus bas selon les journées mais sur
le fond les Français sont hostiles à
cette réforme des retraites le 7 mars
vous appelez à déblocage un peu partout
par exemple cette France morte qui
s'appelle les syndicats le blocage c'est
pas une fin en soi ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas le blocage c'est
ce que le gouvernement tire comme
conclusion de tout ça la stratégie des
syndicats qui veulent mettre la France à
l'arrêt est-ce que pour vous il faut
mettre la France à l'arrêt les syndicats
prendre le responsabilités et évidemment
lorsque les Français veulent exprimer un
mécontentement ils ont ce moyen qui est
la grève et qui effectivement a des
conséquences qui est d'empêcher le pays
dans la majorité on entend des voix dire
c'est pas acceptable c'est c'est
irresponsable
ce qui est des grèves est-ce que c'est
des grèves évidemment et des
conséquences qui soient plus difficiles
de circuler plus difficile de travailler
ce jour-là c'est le principe même de la
grève elle est gênante mais pour sortir
du blocage il y avait
aujourd'hui c'est pas notre rôle en
revanche
contre la réforme de la CSG oui le truc
qui me gêne je vais vous dire brads
bradsous avec des gens qui ont fait
élire Emmanuel Macron comme Martinez
berger c'est quand même totalement
hypocrite parce que c'est un peu quand
même les pompiers Pyroman ils ont fait
rire Emmanuel Macron pour ne pas où ils
ont fait battre Marine Le Pen chacun le
voit comme il veut en tous les cas ils
ont abouti ça abouti à l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait dit qu'il
ferait cette réforme des retraites et
maintenant ils urne parce que cette
réforme des retraites sur le tapis
fallait pas faire élire Emmanuel Macron
fallait faire élire la candidate qui a
un projet qui était 40 à nuité départ à
60 ans mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui alors
que le Parlement est contraint par les
articles 47 1 49.3 la pression de la rue
n'est pas la seule solution pour faire
retirer ce texte non il y a trois outils
dans une démocratie il y a trois outils
j'allais dire il y a l'outil de la
pression populaire de la rue à
l'extérieur il y a l'outil du débat au
Parlement et on a vu que ça marchait
bien quand on va quand on utilise cet
outil ça veut dire que nos institutions
elles ont du sens et
on verra parce que si son but c'est de
faire passer cette réforme qui est un
véritable choix de société à coup de
49-3 ça aura ça un fera d'être du
ressentiment dans la société française
et peut-être même au-delà je leur dis
d'être très précautionneux de faire très
attention à la brutalité avec laquelle
il pourrait faire voter cette réforme de
retraite et puis il y a le débat dans la
société ou qu'elle vous concourrez les
médias en faisant en invitant des gens
qui sont favorables défavorables à cette
réforme des retraites ce qui permet de
faire aussi évoluer l'opinion publique
est-ce que vous comprenez la prise de
recul d'Emmanuel Macron du président de
la République sur ce sujet qu'il a
pourtant portement porté pendant la
campagne électorale je crois que le
Président de la République est perdu
mais ça fait longtemps je crois qu'il
est perdu depuis les législatives il n'a
pas compris il pensait que les Français
allaient lui donner majorité il n'a pas
compris que les Français
majoritairement ne l'avaient pas réélu
pour lui pour son programme que c'est
plus complexe que ça probablement et
donc je crois que c'est un président qui
avait perdu qui ne comprend pas les
Français totalement
hors sol d'ailleurs il suffirait pour
lui de regarder ce qui se passe dans le
pays pour comprendre que les Français
n'adhèrent pas à sa politique pour
comprendre que il y a une brutalité dans
sa politique et pour comprendre que
l'ubérisation de notre société le monde
du travail n'est pas une réponse en soi
les Français veulent trouver un monde du
travail industriel avec des emplois de
qualité le président de la République a
une vision qu'il s'efface un peu selon
vous je crois qu'il n'a pas grand chose
à dire aux Français aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet je pense que le Président
de la République devrait effectivement
s'exprimer mais devrait retirer cette
réforme vous savez on peut on peut se
tromper dans la vie où on peut tout
simplement proposer quelque chose qui ne
recueille pas la sentiment des Français
et à ce moment-là c'est une grandeur
c'est faire oeuvre de grandeur que de le
retirer et de dire on convoquera par
exemple une grande conférence sur
l'emploi des seniors une grande
conférence sur les salaires là encore
nous on a proposé que les salaires
augmentent de 10% jusqu'à 3 fois le SMIC
en échangeait des cotisations patronales
là encore la gauche absent pas là euh
totalement irresponsable mais on dit
Emmanuel Macron il y a des grands
projets de société dont on veut débattre
l'emploi des seniors la hausse des
salaires le coût de la vie le pouvoir
d'achat enfin vous rendez compte
l'inflation au mois de mars sur
l'alimentaire ce que ça va donner il y a
des grands rendez-vous auquel il
pourrait qu'il pourrait prendre avec les
Français malheureusement il choisit de
brutaliser pour des raisons idéologiques
parce qu'il veut dire à la fin j'ai
réussi à faire passer quelque chose mais
quand on réussit à faire passer quelque
chose faut pas le faire contre les
Français merci Sébastien Chenu merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin assembler on se calme c'est à la
Une de La Dépêche
êche l'autre journal tristesse merci
beaucoup on passe au club de territoire